oh my goodness it's a gorgeous piece
it's so incredible it has made a grown
men weep
it's
it's pure beauty
[Music]
hey Mr Wonderful here doing what I love
to do picking up a brand new watch now
in this case
AP adamos gate now let me tell you
what's amazing about this brand the
Octagon that design that you see so
often in the Royal Oak you can recognize
this piece across the room there's no
question about it but let me tell you
something back in 1972 when this piece
was introduced to the world all the
critics crew put it it was not well
received which tells you something never
listen to the critics ever they know
nothing you listen to your heart does it
connect and does it tell a story
the AP Royal Oak tells a story and a
blue dial with a steel case on a red
band
smoking hot
of course it is now my whole point is
when you build your portfolio over time
and if you're a collector you get to be
known by the brand it takes decades but
I'm getting to a point here where I've
got so many watches when I want to bring
in a new story I need something that is
so coveted so hard to get so hard to
find the Royal Oak steel open Work One
of a Kind Shark Tank watch
a smoking hot dream let alone a watch
we started talking about this project
three years ago to make a piece that
would really bust out in season 15 on
Shark Tank that no other shark would
ever have that would be the centerpiece
of the fashionista man himself Mr
Wonderful
the thing I love about this brand this
Maison is they understand the fashion
aspect of collecting watches and in the
last 10 years what's gotten really hot
is being able to change the bands now
you know I can only wear a red band so I
have to get a red band for every piece I
make an AP accommodates me they have all
kinds of Integrations that make this
possible that's why I love this Maison
that's why I love the house they
understand where I'm coming from I gotta
have red and they search the world for
the very best red bands to work in these
pieces but their new Snap-on technology
which came out recently and is really
part of this wonderful new collection
the overseas the music the watch I call
the music we're going to see her today
also fantastic integration with multiple
colors so all of this is going to happen
today you're going to go on a wild ride
you're going to see what happens
went for the first moment
you lay your eyes on a one of a kind
never made before never seen before
Royal Oak open work
ruby red
Shark Tank
Mega watch
[Music]
ah how are you welcome Mr Larry great to
be here thank you so much it's our
pleasure and guess what it's that time
we're gonna make magic happen today
unbelievable it's been two and a half
years in the making yes this is the
Magic Moment
very few times in your life do you come
to pick up a one of a kind particularly
an AP an open work the master class
piece with rubies steel ready for season
15 Shark Tank planned this two and a
half years ago I have never seen it yet
only pictures I'm gonna see the real
thing so as you know and as we know red
is your color yes it is okay yes it is
so we're not gonna skip a beat when it
comes to that no point trying to sell me
any other color no this is what I have
to have and if I pull back my shirt
sleeve and it's not a red band it's
chaos yes we have clients who actually
when they do purchase a red strap they
say this is Mr Wonderful well I'm glad
to hear that but I think it's great
because it's it's striking it's great
with my black suit I always wear and you
do such a great job of Designing
different textures I mean it's this is
beautiful stuff and obviously for a
sports piece which I can consider this
to be and I want to wear this in the
summer getting a band that's going to be
able to sustain the heat around my wrist
is important but still the clasp is AP
so it's keeping all the Heritage that's
what I want the quality is never skipped
so that's something that we need to
always make sure that even if we try to
make a watch yours we still keep the
quality the same fantastic let's talk
about when this watch came to the market
for the first time Gerald designed this
right yes so just for clarity I'm not a
historian but I do know a bit about this
watch one reason why people don't
understand why we even call it a jumbo
okay now tell us about that sure so when
we released a 39 millimeter in 1972 it
was the biggest watch everything was
much smaller 35 to 38 exactly the 35 36
yeah you're thinking about a period
where most watches were either on strap
and here it comes uh Audemars piguet
saying look we're gonna make a watch
even bigger so we're gonna make a 39
millimeter and now it's a standard size
exactly now we I mean since we've done
many versions many variations of the
Royal Oak if you know AP you know a
jumbo yeah I in fact I can't even
imagine collecting and not having a
jumbo it's a core Cornerstone in the
collection everybody says let's see your
jumbo yes if you don't have it it's an
embarrassment it's a hole yes but
let's be realistic we don't make too
many watches
it's true but there's a secondary Market
unfortunately sometimes you have to go
to the secondary market and buy vintage
to fill up you know I always tell people
look don't go into debt in watch
collecting but as you go through life
and if you're successful in business and
you start to want to reward yourself as
I do every deal I close it's another
watch I'm at that stage in my life where
I've you know built a reputation with
the makers I'm known as a collector and
so when you get to that place once in a
while
a brand will make you a one of a kind
today I'm picking up just such a piece
let's talk about it exactly so just uh
we talk about this piece it actually was
released in 2016. so we didn't have a
double balance wheel open work prior to
this and the story here is very unique
as well this piece was really put on the
map by Francois and his uh his
watchmaking team it was never on the
books to design this watch it was an
accident
so
Francois was touring the manufacturing
and saw a watchmaker with this watch on
one of his first questions believe it or
not was that does the watch actually
work
because it was so open it was so unique
he wanted to make sure that the watch
tells time besides its beauty so now we
fast forward it's 2023 you've been
waiting a long time yeah but is it
unique let's see here we are
what we've been waiting for
yep
just give me a moment to prepare sure
take your time
two and a half years in the making but
you have to understand about watch
collecting is
it's a slow art
it's it's figuring out where to go next
and starting the journey and the
destination is years away that's what
happened here you have to work with the
designers to design it that takes years
itself and then they have to make it
and then the moments comes when you see
it for the first time
let's go
okay
it's magistry
yes
oh my goodness it's a gorgeous piece
it's so incredible
it has made a grown man weep
it's
it's pure beauty it's unbelievable it's
incredible I can't believe I'm holding
it
yes it's here and this is the best part
of my job
is to Unwell these pieces to our clients
the only one in the world
incredible
this watch is going to become a legend
if it's not already yeah yes
but we need to let everybody know that
besides the fact that you've made this
watch there's a hint in there that it's
only yours which is the second hand
reader and it's pure red yeah
when we were designing it
I begged the team is there any way we
can put
this red element to match the rubies
which are stunning in themselves
placing this incredible Aura of red
matching it to the second hand in red I
mean it's it's
unbelievable it's stunning
and that's what makes our watches unique
it's those little hints it's very subtle
but it tells a story and it's telling a
story about someone like you who loves
this color who loves the brand and who
loves this who loves his timepieces
now can you imagine a red band on this
piece
I've been waiting for that not only is
one of a kind but the red on the steel
on the red on the open work which has
got these wonderful tones in the dial I
mean it's just an incredible piece it
just screams
oh my goodness let's let's go through
the process show us how this red band
remember this piece was born with the
steel
band but now because AP has the adapter
kits to do this we can actually make it
something truly unique and ready for
television I mean can you imagine this
piece on TV this is going to be insane
insane but that's what watchmaking is
all about that's what watch collecting
is all about to give those amazing
moments those stories the story of this
watch is Legend let's put the Red Band
on
[Music]
an absolute pillar in my collection a
probably you know one of the greatest
pieces that I've got no question about
it it's going to it's going to really
get a big coming out party there's no
question I mean
this will be conversations for a year at
least
all right guys thank you so much